[Music]
hi I'm Serena I'm a PhD student at the
University of Washington and I've been
at Microsoft since 2015 working on farm
beats a low-cost system for data driven
agriculture with farm beats were trying
to solve the world's food problem that
is by the year 2050 we need to increase
the world's food production by 70% in
order to feed the growing population and
one promising solution to enable this is
data-driven agriculture however most
existing solutions are just too
expensive with farmers who are enabling
a low cost and dense systems for
data-driven agriculture by solving by
providing three key innovations the
first is connectivity so most farms are
located in very rural areas where there
is no internet connectivity so the
farmers who might have connectivity but
his farm might be several miles away so
the way we provide connectivity on the
farm is by using TV white spaces TV
white spaces is unused TV spectrum that
you can leverage to extend Wi-Fi like
connectivity over to the farm so we use
TV white spaces to now have Internet
connectivity on the farm the next step
is that we need to collect data so you
would deploy sensors out in the field to
collect data like soil moisture however
sensors are very expensive so we need a
very sparse sensor deployment while
still having accurate data collection so
with farm beats we deploy a few sensors
out in a farm and then what we do is
take a drone fly it over the field to
collect aerial images and then we take
those images to stitch a panorama view
now with our sensor data and the
panorama we can create precision maps of
soil moisture pH temperature and
humidity for instance this is a
precision map of soil moisture where
this light color here show
shows the swells very moist and red is
very dry so now instead of irrigating
the whole farm uniformly a farmer can
use this map and only water the area
where where it's necessary some of the
other insights we provide are things
like microclimate prediction
often times farmers need to have
accurate data accurate weather data to
perform their tasks for instance a
farmer that is spraying his fields needs
to know wind direction and wind speed
with farm beats we can deploy sensors
that collect such data like wind speed
wind direction ambient temperature
humidity to provide microclimate
predictions in addition to that we can
make predictions about data that were
not collecting for instance leaf wetness
a few other things that we do is animal
monitoring here we're actually showing
our algorithm to make detection Xand
it's detecting people and we can
actually apply that to detect animals
this shows a deployment in New York
where we're monitoring the farmers cows
and we can track their movements how
they're grazing and make predictions
about their health so with farm beats we
can provide all these all these insights
and all this data but the second problem
is we can't ship all this data to the
cloud it's a lot of information ok you
can can you imagine having to ship every
single image that you collected from the
drone video so when we generate these
precision Maps we're making them several
orders of magnitude smaller so from
gigabytes to 100 kilobytes that then get
uploaded to the cloud this is really
important because oftentimes even though
we have internet connection the system
is not reliable we can have weather
outages that make the system go down for
weeks this way we do all our local
computer computation at a farmer's PC so
all of his important insights are
available immediately and are available
offline but then when internet
connectivity is available we ship these
very small summaries up to the cloud and
then
that allows us to even do cross farm
analytics
[Music]
you